Jerry this is gay Sophia they actually
call them the Seinfeld a friend oh yeah
who does everyone that's here in France
who did this represent a trip visiting
the family I'm sorry van flag - not
dangerous era at all I am convenient
very famous dance wall in France yeah
hmm what I don't know he's just not here
exactly I see you were assistant to
David Spade
well actually I shadowed David Spade's
assistant and if you follow it down to
the bottom there it says shadow yeah but
these all have the Astra's so yeah say
yeah seriously
it came here I want her fulfill my
duties as a father I'm one of the models
and you're mr. Alan Ross no but I'm his
father biologically but the man I
consider my actual father couldn't be
here Jason Allen Ross aren't you popular
and like France or something yeah it
doesn't matter right because it's not
the US exactly you know that's it I'm
done with comedy I walked away from it
good
so hey comedy we don't do a lot of
comedy around the house it's a serious
time in the world these days it's not a
lot of room for laughter
I can't let Jason Alan Ross raise myself
who worships this Jason guy he waxes he
times how can I compete you got this you
wanna help ya go back to Paris you're a
king there God never too late you know
that's sane too little too late do you
know that one it's legit who's this guy
let's just cat it's cool doesn't look
cool what
yeah he's French
[Music]
you